all right um try to climb that tree dude
yeah oh wait hang on
this one do it again and wait yeah yeah
oh this is so sick
a guy I got it dude I got it yeah your
turn all right I'll do it right um I'm
just gonna jump I will cut it together
to look like I did it okay yeah all
right okay that'll do right
you gotta get another foot off the
ground no it wasn't I got it all right
yeah yeah man I'm gonna hurt all over
that bench settings right yeah okay mine
shut
yeah get it get it yeah yeah no I got it
here I don't want you hurt on camera all
right yeah
leap over me there's gonna be good feels
so sick dude that's so sick ah I think I
got it yeah I got it I got it what's
good okay I look good yeah but I didn't
oh please Jesus Christ I play games for
a living I can't run
yeah yeah this is good I like a bench
that do it yeah man oh my god
no nobody wait okay do it nice
you should caber toss it oh hell yeah do
that caber toss myself every night
this isn't illegal is it uh this illegal
hey you know be really cool you threw it
over me okay you got it as well
oh oh oh dude
is it camera okay the camera okay you
broke it over me what you broke it over
me Liz knows like that oh my god
bees bees bees feet oh man what can be
dude they swarm it like a moment's
notice
dude it's a condom oh yeah yeah it dead
you can talk to me you know if you need
to know well good good rent yeah sad
dude
markiplier no sad dude yeah I'm like 27
years old I can't do that - uh dude I'm
here with my main man Tyler he's gonna
be helping me make the best quality
videos from now on we're gonna be going
out we're gonna be doing sick flips uh
[Music]
bark or we're gonna be doing a lot of
that just do it again hang on dude
I don't like that you do it hang on I
want to see you do it and then go for it
did and you do so good I'm not gonna
back but in I'm here oh by the way
Tyler's
[Music]